these russian forces are seen by western
officials as a key indicator of russia's
plans for ukraine
they've been training in next door
belarus just a few hours drive from the
ukrainian capital
the drills should have ended but instead
they've been extended raising western
fears that an invasion is imminent
in the suburbs of kiev all is not yet
lost
last-ditch diplomacy saw france's
president speak again to russia's
vladimir putin
they agreed on the need for a diplomatic
solution and said talks would continue
but on the ground hennedy is taking no
chances
he volunteers to help provide security
for the residents
this basement will become a makeshift
bomb shelter in an emergency and how
safe is it
i'm not safe because
it's a full
become
yeah
it's safe enough even for a missile yes
over the past three weeks he says he
stocked up on generators fuel and a
water tank in case of an attack
it can happen in our
in the few hours in
last
future night future week we don't know
what we're ready at least 10 000 people
live in these tower blocks some of
kiev's 2.8 million residents it's a
population the u.s president said would
be at risk if russia really does decide
not just to attack but to launch an
attack that targets the capital
in the east of the country ukrainian
forces are already coming under
increasing fire from russia-backed
separatists
information used as a weapon too with
ukraine saying it's being falsely
accused of attacking separatist-held
areas
a russian hand is also suspected by many
here in events that shook kiev eight
years ago
they commemorate the bloodiest days from
an uprising against the then government
which had been seeking closer ties with
moscow
irina's teenage son was among the dozens
of protesters killed by sniper fire
she doesn't believe he died in vain and
is ready to fight herself should russia
invade
it's a defiance that's shared
and may soon have to be tested
sky news kiev